así es como dejo
elliot a mi casa
si ven cómo quedó totalmente destruido
arelis fonseca tiene 48 años y vive en
la montaña un barrio del norte de la
isla colombiana de providencia
mis hijas todavía se despiertan
cuando empieza a gritar fuerte a llover
se despiertan gritando toca armarla de
hacerles ver que no que no están en ese
día el día del que habla es el 16 de
noviembre de 2020 es en el que por el
paso del huracán yo está lo perdió todo
y se convirtió en uno de los miles de
damnificados que dejó el fenómeno hoy la
mañana es clemente así que aprovecha
para prepararle el desayuno aimar su
hija menor con unas salchichas que
reclamó con el bono de alimentos para
los afectados antes de que se
descompongan por la falta de
refrigeración una cosa como de locos
en el bono digan
se exija que tú tienes que hacer una
sola compra cuando saben que mucha gente
no tiene luz
y el 80 imagino más o menos no tenemos
donde conservar los alimentos
antes de liotta ofrecía el servicio de
masajes en el espacio que había adecuado
en su casa ahora su prioridad es
recolectar lo necesario para suplir las
necesidades básicas toca desde allá la
señora que ve al frente
me hace el favor y me regala agua porque
eso sí ha sido más difícil el
carrotanque no pasa siempre y cuando uno
va en una lista de espera
pero la penuria de arelis no es la única
en este paraíso que el yo está
transformó en un infierno para sus más
de cinco mil habitantes
solo a pocos metros en el sector de
maracaibo la familia de glass ford
jaguar no tuvo más opción que sumar
escombros para levantar su refugio
a mí me dijeron que yo estaba en una
lista para recibir las 10 casas que
venían y que estaba entre esa primera
lista
estoy esperando todavía no han llegado
las casas
entre el matorral en el que se convirtió
el jardín en el que glass force y luz
marina cultivaban vegetales y frutas su
hijo son y denuncian que aunque redes
sociales y comunicados oficiales el
gobierno colombiano dice que la
reconstrucción avanza a buen ritmo lo
que vive en ellos y cientos más
demuestra lo contrario unidad nacional
de gestión de riesgo
los funcionarios del gobierno cruz roja
y defensa civil aquí están de vacaciones
en estas robustas carpas se reúnen los
encargados de la reconstrucción del
archipiélago a la cabeza hasta el
ministro de vivienda de colombia
jonathan malagón quien sobre el progreso
del llamado plan 100 asegura que han
sido exigentes donde hemos puesto unos
programas muy estrictos queremos a
finales de abril tener 50 viviendas
nuevas construidas intervenidas casi 900
entre techos y mejoramientos completos
que hayamos logrado sacar adelante
aunque familias como la de glass for
hardware han decidido reconstruir por su
cuenta la falta de soluciones por parte
de los encargados de la gestión el
ministro- malagón afirma que este tipo
de labores también han sido acordadas
contrario a lo que dicen los afectados
muchas de las familias nos han dicho que
prefieren que le reparen su casa en
lugar de una vivienda nueva numerosas
denuncias sobre la presunta adulteración
de los listados de viviendas pendientes
por ser reconstruidas y reparadas han
salido a la luz en las últimas semanas
ante lo que el gobierno señala que es
posible que aumente
el número de las que deban ser demolidas
mientras no reconstruyen ni providencia
ni su vecina santa catalina donde se
vive el mismo desespero y la misma
desolación podrán reabrir al turismo que
representa más del 80 por ciento de su
economía
josefina huffington la mayor autoridad
raizal de la isla también resultó
afectada todavía no hay la primera casa
hecha
en junio nuevamente comienza el periodo
de huracanes
providencia y todo el archipiélago
que era muy vulnerable hacia eso
sin soluciones a la vista arelis
adoptado por habilitar una camilla de
masajes bajo su carpa y recurrido a las
luces de navidad que rescató de la
corriente para iluminar el espacio en el
que ofrece sus servicios
primero pandemia huracán post huracán
que todavía es peor que el mismo momento
porque este es un momento mucho más
largo no sabemos hasta cuándo era
tampoco
al finalizar este reportaje según el
gobierno habían sido reparados las
cubiertas de al menos 360 viviendas 6
contaban con reparaciones integrales
finalizadas lo que equivale al 12 por
ciento de la meta del plan que vence el
10 de abril los damnificados a los que
seguimos durante varios días afirmaron
que al menos para ellos todo sigue igual